welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news coming out of Russia where
investigators have just confirmed that
the mercenary chief of Guinea pregosian
was killed in a plane crash last week
let's cross over to dorsa Jabari who
joins us now on the phone from Moscow
and dorsa the speculation as to whether
progosian was on the plane has now
really been confirmed it seems
yes absolutely
put out by the investigative committee
and the statement says that according to
the results of the examination that They
carried out on genetic testing so it's
been completed and they can report that
the identity of all 10 people who died
in the plane crash in the tibia region
on Wednesday evening they have been
confirmed and they do correspond to the
list of the flight manifests
which had the list of passengers on
board so they are confirming that you're
getting pagosian alongside his right
hand man
um has been identified as the victim
that the victims of their crash that
took place on Wednesday what we did see
and hear uh when that crash happened
dors was very little publicity given to
it in the Press now do you think this is
going to change in any way as the news
has confirmed that pagosian is dead
but I think that will really depend on
how the Kremlin wants to play this
um given that you know he had a falling
out with the Russian President Vladimir
Putin as a result of that attempted
um Mutiny two months ago
um and uh the head of the Wagner groups
tried to reach Moscow to make his views
that he didn't believe the Russia
president would fit stay in office and
also the head of the military was to
blame for
um get assaults that they've had
according to him in the
conflict in Ukraine so I think it's
really going to be up to Vladimir Putin
how he wants to spin this now we saw him
speak on Friday break his site on
Thursday rather
um he broke his silence and he did
comments he did save and he was also
cautious at that time he said that if
the results proved to be true that if
Katie Collision was on board he was a um
a man who made a lot of mistakes and he
had a difficult fate but he did manage
to achieve his goals and he did talk
about his relationship with his guinea
pig ocean which dates back to the early
1990s
um I think there has been the sense here
is that they have downplayed uh his
death because they don't want to elevate
his status to something other than what
it is but
I've been speaking to people in
and went to one of the makeshift
memorials last night where I saw the
people they were just quite upset about
his passing and they said you know
regardless of what transpired uh she is
a hero of Russia of course also it does
clarify for those individuals that were
working for the Wagner group as to
what's happened to their boss in for
want of a better word does it also mean
now that they in some shape or form have
to make some serious decisions as to
whether they want to stay with the
Wagner group or that they may be
um happy to to merge into the Russian
military I mean perhaps they do have a
choice now as to what happens to their
own futures
uh whether or not to stay or move toward
to the ministry of Defense in within
Russia but I think now after Vladimir
Putin signed a decree on
um Friday saying that even the the
people who are part of uh various
military armed groups they have to
pledge allegiance to the Russian
Constitution it doesn't really make a
difference they all fall under the same
umbrella basically according to the laws
of Russia and meaning that they say
um act against the interest of the
Constitution they will redeem those
Traders I think it's an attempt by the
Russian president to really rein in
groups like The Wagner group and to
prevent uh events happening like they
did two months ago in attempted Mutiny
so uh whether and they do certainly the
the remaining members of the group have
to make decisions and we understand that
they have been meeting there's been
committing teachings within the upper
echelon of the Wagner group over the
past few days to try and decide how to
move forward but of course they're very
secretive and we don't know if they have
appointed a new head of the group if
they are still deciding it's unclear at
the moment but certainly we understand
that if getting purgation had put in
place certain number of
um contingency plans uh predicting that
if this ever happened to him that those
plans should come into play and as far
as various media reports of course I'm
confirmed those are those plans are in
motion and the meetings are taking place
we'll hopefully know soon what will be
the future of this Wagner group as we
understand it to be
thanks very much George of course uh
that breaking news coming out of Russia
that it's now being confirmed that you
have any pregosian uh has been declared
dead in that plane crash earlier in the
week Dr jabaria correspondent there in
Moscow